[Musique]
imaginez que c'est quand même tant
l'émotion et la fierté que je ressens ce
matin
je pense aussi à tous nos électeurs je
pense à ces millions de français qui
sont privés d'une représentation juste à
l'assemblée nationale depuis pour
certains des décennies et qui ce matin
enfin je crois se sentent représentés
[Musique]
écoutez moi je voudrais moi je marche
sur deux jambes jeunes droite et une
jambe gauche au sérieux en même temps
c'est ça on est de droite et de gauche
c'est qu'on est là pour à la fois
protéger les français libérés et ont
fait les deux
de conduite elle est extrêmement claire
nous sommes un groupe d'opposition
mais nous allons peut-être qu'il va
devenir dans cette configuration
totalement inédite un groupe
d'opposition qui va être en mesure de
négocier des avancées pour les français
[Musique]
on
donc
[Musique]